aaron rodgers has tested positive for
covet 19. and as a result he won't be on
the field this sunday when the green bay
packers take on the kansas city chiefs
according to cbs sports nfl insider
jason la canfora the quarterback tested
positive shortly after practice squad
quarterback kurt benkert also tested
positive this setback for rogers leaves
an open door for jordan love who is the
only other quarterback on the packers
roster guaranteeing him the opportunity
to start against patrick mahomes and the
chiefs as for when we'll see rogers
return to the field nfl protocol
requires that he quarantine for a
minimum of 10 days which also places
question marks around the packers
november 19 match up with the seattle
seahawks
are you vaccinated and what's your
stance on vaccinations yeah i've been
immunized that was rogers in august
telling reporters he was quote immunized
now that he's tested positive for the
virus there's been some confusion about
his vaccination status ian rappaport of
the nfl network reports that rogers is
unvaccinated which may explain why he
used the word immunized meaning he's
built up natural antibodies from
possibly contracting the virus in the
past
are you vaccinated and what's your
stance on vaccinations yeah i've been
immunized according to a source who
spoke with espn the athlete had an
alternative treatment prior to the start
of training camp rogers then petitioned
the nfl for that treatment to allow him
to be considered the same as someone who
received one of the approved vaccines
the league ultimately ruled rogers would
be considered unvaccinated
with that there is concern around what
nfl covet 19 protocols rogers has been
following up until this point if rogers
is vaccinated he can return to the team
once he's symptom-free and produces two
negative tests within a 24 hour period
[Music]